well my biggest hope is in fact that
there is a future to the Arctic as it
looks now we are changing the Arctic in
such a fundamental way that perhaps what
we once considered the Arctic as a far
removed place that it would be difficult
to get to is changing the Arctic may in
fact become a very easy and accessible
place to go to but then it would no
longer be the Arctic it actually would
be a melting Arctic and it would change
fundamentally the way we look at the
world and the way the world would appear
to us because the temperature of the
world would rise so much that the whole
structure and infrastructure and
ecosystem of the world would change I
often say that when I think about the
word future I think about the poet the
20th century French poet Paul availabe
who said the future isn't what it used
to be and it strikes me that the future
of the Arctic is in our hands and we can
probably reverse the way in which the
Arctic is being destroyed by being
actively engaged in social change
you
you